[Music]
jargon gets a bad reputation for good
reasons but there's something good about
jargon and I think it should be explored
because jargon hangs on I think in our
speech because it has a usefulness when
people in the same profession have a
word that stands for five pages of
written knowledge why say five pages of
stuff when you can say one word and if
the other person understands it exactly
the way you understand it then jargon
has usefulness the trouble is we develop
such specialized words that they're not
understood by people at just a little
distance from art our expertise for
instance even showbusiness which you
wouldn't expect to have a technical
jargon or you might not be you might not
expect it even show business has its
moviemaking take this gobo and put it on
the century over there and hurry up
because this is the martini shot and
while you're at it bring me a half Apple
what that's not understood to most
people and it's crystal clear that
somebody who's been on a movie set for a
while I guess I have to explain that her
people will be writing your letter
saying whoa what what does all that mean
a gobo is a thing that blocks out like a
century is a century Stan made by the
century company many decades ago and
there their name is understand and sixth
and that holds up a light or a gobo the
martini shot is the last shot of the day
before you go home and have a martini
and a half Apple is a box half the size
of an Apple box that you can put things
on like people who are too short
something that's jargon for the movie
said but jargon is has another evil use
aside from separating us from one
another and that is that when we want to
use it to make it make ourselves look
really smart I'm smart I talk like this
you can't really talk like this so
you're not as smart
me a lot of us do this unconsciously and
it's not necessary we get more done if
we open ourselves up it's really fun to
be on the verge of saying something that
is probably not going to be understood
by the other person
and to say wait a second how can I say
this in really plain language and if we
do that sometimes we learn more about
the jargon and we thought we knew we
humanize it we reduce it to the simplest
concepts concepts whether the concepts
that really matter in this and then the
jargon sometimes gets cleaned up and
polished of some of the luster of
highfalutin looks that doesn't help it
doesn't help the jargon be helpful the
choice of words does matter matters a
lot but I think that it's important to
remember that if all we do is get the
right words in our head in the right
order of words and think that that's
going to make all by itself good
communication I think we're missing the
boat because real really effective
communication is not just because I have
something perfect to say to you it
really occurs when you understand and
internalize what I had to say and are
able to make it your own to remember it
and that kind of thing here's an
interesting example of that one of our
medical students who were training to
communicate better was on rounds with a
supervising MD and the doctor who was in
charge was talking to a patient and he
had to explain to her that she had
incurable cancer and she was going to
die and he was talking to her and as he
was telling her these you know all this
really hard to take information she
wasn't asking questions and you could
tell by the look on her face or at least
the young the medical student could tell
by the look on her face that she wasn't
understanding it she was just listening
would kind of a blank expression and the
lead doctor said okay so talk to you
later or whatever he said and let left
and the young doctors a medical student
said do you mind if I stay for a few
minutes with her and talk to her and he
was given permission to do that so now
he sat down right opposite her and took
her hand in his and he started to say
many of the same things that the other
doctor had said but he didn't use the
same words so the words changed
he didn't say metastasis he talked in
simpler terms but he was making contact
with her he was looking at her eyes he
was opening himself up to her as he
talked to her and little by little she
started to cry and she started to ask
questions and finally she understood she
was going to die and he helped her
through that understanding he helped her
get that understanding because she
wasn't protected against this barrage of
impersonal communication that the other
dr. Haddix ed had been giving her and
what he said though is what this young
doctor said to us this is a medical
student was that it brought him back to
one of our basic exercises as a
mirroring exercise where he has to
mirror the movements of another person
and when that happens well you get in
sync and he said I was mirroring her and
then she began to mirror me because she
helped me be a better doctor because she
responded with tears to what I was
saying which let me know she really
understood me he was so moved by the
experience that he began
to cry himself and the experience and I
don't think he was crying because he
felt her pain at the awareness that she
was going to die I think he was moved
because that this connection had taken
place and he realized that the movement
he had made during the workshops to be
able to make this kind of contact with
another person was a profound experience
and he said that he would never forget
the experience and how it came from the
simple mirroring exercise so that was a
wonderful experience for us to hear
about because it was a personal way of
letting us know that people can be
changed by this
[Music]